you think about a product make just make
sure you make one customer
really really happy so don't focus like
making everybody a little bit happy
just find this one customer right they
make really really happy and then kind
of worry about the second one make them
really really happy
and then the third one eventually if you
make people really really happy they're
gonna bring their friends and so on
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc
fund in silicon valley and is sponsored
by leumitech hippo insurance
touring upwards labs and hillel at
stanford sales and sales
sales welcome elon chef co-founder and
chief product officer of gong io
elon is a co-founder and the chief
product officer at gong gong is the
leading solution provider in the revenue
intelligence space
helping revenue teams understand how to
help their team members succeed
how to better track deals and how to
understand the voice of the market
gong is a high growth sas vendor and
recently announced the funding round
with a 2.2 billion dollar valuation
prior to gong elon was a co-founder of
web collage a sas provider in the
marketing infrastructure space
following many years in various roles in
the software space
airlon resides in tel aviv israel but
used to visit the us
often prior to covet hey lon reshef
thank you for joining me
all the way from california ganga yo i'm
so excited to speak to you
nice being here good morning
good morning good evening you know it's
a covet a global world it doesn't even
matter anymore what matters is that
we're going to talk about your journey
we're going to talk about sales
we're going to talk about product and
everything somehow combined
towards building really incredible
companies to say the least
and you know there's so much out there
about you know your journey and gang io
but what i'm excited
to talk to you about these 20 minutes is
a little bit about you and your journey
and your love for products
and also a little bit about sales and
what you're doing so elon
take me all the way all the way back to
you know weitzman institute and
to a web collage and answers tell me
about your journey a little bit
oh my journey begins many many years ago
it was in the previous
century and so like many others started
as the other
yeah that early so like many others
started as a young kid in this
development had my own like small
business around developing software
um in israel as you know you go to the
uh
through your military service done that
done a little bit of programming there
and i worked in one public company magic
software enterprises which was the first
israeli software company to go public on
an aspect so that was pretty cool
um i then went to a small startup called
zappa at the time
john scully ex chairman of apple yes uh
was our chairman essentially 3d awards
still do not exist that was back in last
century
then started my own company in the
beginning of this century so web collage
did software as a service for content
marketing
and after we've sold it in 2013 took a
sabbatical
and then started um gone with an event
on my partner here
unbelievable and and you know your
journey is it's it's
i think there's a really interesting
intersection here of of product and
technology right because you're you're
an engineer by profession but you're
you're gravitated towards
you know both vp product back then
in this in you know the early 2000s and
now chief product officer but
even now you were a chief technology
officer of gom
so can you talk to me a little bit about
how these two roles fit together because
it's not that common
to have a chief product officer also be
able to assimilate the role of a chief
technology officer
yeah right it was it was it was kind of
chance because
you're right i mean it's very common
that engineers eventually become product
managers it's kind of you know to become
a product manager either you have a
strong business
background or strong engineering
background or sometimes other things
right
so that's a pretty common route so i
kind of moved to new york i spent a few
years with the business became
like a real product manager um in my
previous company at some stage we just
replaced it ahead of
and i stayed pretty close to technology
just because it's kind of a hobbit
hobby for me and then at some stage
we're looking for we were placing a head
of
engineering and the ceo came to me and
said would you mind doing this for a few
years or whatever until we saw the
company i'm like oh i don't know but
let's do it anyway
and so i kind of had i ended up like
running i could manage people that was
like a
you know skill set kind of technology
engineering i kind of know because i've
been following this so it's it's kind of
been
it's been nice for a few years and then
when we started the dog i told my
partner amit you know
i actually want to do product he was
like so who's going to write the code
i'm like oh no we're going to find
somebody who's going to write a code
he's like you know why don't you start a
little bit
so i ended up like writing the whole
prototype with just one more person on
my own and then it sort of evolved
involved at some stages because it
became this like
big monster when i mean monsters like
startup ones right 40 people
and at some stage we kind of said hey um
this is like not what
i'm you know necessarily best at so
let's kind of find somebody who's more
professional at managing engineering
organizations
and then i just kind of focus on product
which is fun i love pro i
i love how you're just you know skimming
through this as if it's you know
overnight but you know we're talking
about six years of hard work
accumulating to
you know a market leader right now in in
the world of sales you know over 300
million dollars raised
from sequoia battery wing vc i mean
really you know
the people that you that you get to i'm
so incredibly jealous just by you know
the people you get to work with and
obviously
they're jealous because they get to work
with you but tell me a little bit about
you know starting out with a mate you
know and you write
you write on your linkedin you're a
wannabe founder for four months as
you're validating this
idea that you might have in the whole
sales world
talk take me back to that time 2015 what
are those four months like
yeah so first of all i took the whole
sabbatical off i recommend to anybody
and everybody right if you can take a
sabbatical that's fun time right so
because the opportunities some of them
were nice some of them weren't nice
there aren't too many like for a whole
year i couldn't even find maybe three
opportunities i was really excited about
but you know starting a new company
there's like an energy to it that cannot
be replaced by coming to work for a
company
and so i kind of originally met amit
when he was trying to recruit me for
he ran a company consistent he was gonna
look at you look for he looked for a vp
of product
um i was busy i was in sabbatical he
looked for somebody in new york which i
left many years ago so that was like a
very short conversation
but when he left sizes to start well it
wasn't vlogging the time right to start
a company we kind of
got back together and what excited me
most was first of all the approach it
was just like
i was i was 100 sure there was a need in
the market even if just one company's
license
but the other thing that kind of excited
me was um
at the time there were so few sales
tools out there so like 3 000 marketing
tools like
100 sales too so it was evident there's
a lot of green space
i think we underestimated the time how
big the gap was
but we're still excited we're gonna
explore this we got somewhere to start
so it was like an obvious
thing to kind of run for so even though
it might not have been obvious at that
moment
now looking back what was the gap that
you realized that there
is in the world of sales so
the gap is is you know it's kind of
fascinating that if you sort of look at
every sales organization in the world
um what what people do is most of the
time they communicate with customers
emails from conversations videos text
messages whatever
and all of this conversation essentially
goes to the garbage right
um nobody can ever find it does it go
the best place is like take notes
put them in some i don't know system crm
evernote whatever
so there's literally no way for any
company on earth to understand what
people are really doing
it's kind of fascinating we're talking
it's already 20 now now we're gonna have
a new year for everybody and then
and it's funny and people still can't
look at what people are doing
so this is amazing it's like how could
it be and i think that's the big gap
and as we probe deeper it's just evident
the gap is huge like you have no idea
what people are doing
it's like 101 right right and and so i
i'm guessing that you know if i would
ask even now
what you're doing even though gong is
already you know making a huge dent
and and it's all has already moved the
needle and there's no going back i'm
guessing that you know in terms of the
vision
you're still just scratching the surface
of what's possible
once you once you have you know any
insight into what's actually happening
right it's it's scratching the surface
both in terms of like number of
salespeople like we got maybe a hundred
thousand people but there's in the war
there's probably tens of millions of
people
and then sort of capabilities yes we're
helping with coaching we're helping with
pipeline management
but we still didn't even like so here's
the thing like every sales conversation
there's action items in the end and the
rep might be saying i'm going to follow
up with an email
we actually know what their email is and
if they don't follow up we never even
remind them so even like we don't even
like provide
some very simplistic advice to the rep
let alone things like onboarding
you know advanced analytics and advice
this is like we're just maybe 10 20
of of where we could be in into three
years
so take me back to when you're assuming
that there is this gap
you know selling selling to sales i've
heard it's not that easy
you know that you know people have their
own methods every everybody does it
perhaps in in a different but similar
way what how did you find
you know selling gong to the very first
customers who who you wanted to adopt
first customers is never easy so i think
there's there's maybe two things one is
focus and people underestimate focus
everybody says focus right
um but so when we started it was like
we're only going to sell to software
companies
business to business in north america we
sell
2015 wasn't that popular video
conferencing over
video conferencing and deals of size is
somewhere between 5 000 and 50 000
dollars
and that and using salesforce.com
and that was pretty much it so that's
probably i don't know how many maybe 10
000 companies in the world of that
category now we're obviously doing phone
and email and many other things say you
know atp is a customer not adam so
um and i think that allows us to sort of
really kind of focus on the key
uh value proposition which is you know
i'm a sales organization
there's a collaboration aspect there's a
multi people to people selling
how can i get a better handle visibility
into what's happening
that core message hasn't changed but we
obviously built it many more
applications so how do you coach to that
how do you manage
pipeline all of these things but
initially it was just giving visibility
into that that things
right so now taking you know going up 30
000 feet
a little bit about you know the sales
world obviously we also have to talk a
little bit about what's happening with
covet in 2020
with how sales has dramatically changed
obviously
you know gang has become incredibly more
relevant in 2020 when now literally
everything is digital but talk to me a
little bit about how sales has
changed you know since we've introduced
you know
digital communication and whether we've
adapted or didn't adapt properly to that
it's a great question and i think what
uh cohen did is really accelerated
everything by five to ten years i don't
think it changed much yeah
so if you still sort of like rewind 10
years ago
uh maybe 15 years ago and most b2b
selling
was down in person so i would take it
plain you know i i did this myself in
the beginning of you know year 2000 like
hop on the plane 8 a.m fly to the
customer you know go to lunch
meet a customer go back to the hotel
sleep meet again fly back two days one
minute two minutes
completely inefficient um it's gradually
shifted towards the digital selling
video conferencing held even web extent
right even though it's like a conference
called help
email help i mean it's kind of office
now everybody has an email but 20 years
ago was done you know can i send big
attachments right
um many other digital tools and i think
it just increases increased efficiency
now what people have been seeing in kofi
many people were like well we can only
close ten thousand dollar deals
well guess what in the last maybe a year
or so
people have been closing seven figure
deals over the phone because there's no
other method
and i think once people get used to this
there's no going back in the sense that
people are still to meet of course
hopefully but they're not going to take
a plane for two days just for one hour
we think it's
not going to happen even if they wanted
to the cfo is going to look and say hey
you can do this in like
an hour and i'm going to spend two
thousand dollars sending you back and
forth
it's not going to happen so i don't
think that's a reversible thing
relationships are still important i
think people are going to
go back to having dinners and lunches
but not maybe
30 of the time versus 90 of it
right and so one of the things that i
think are most fascinating about what
where
where you're standing today you're
you're you know the front forefront of
the digitalization of of you know
insight into sales and
almost you know gong as a market leader
you're dictating you know what what
how do we see you know analytics and
sales and how do we
interact along with with sales people
do you find that your position as chief
product officer over the last
over the last while has changed as gang
is is is you know growing and
is it going to change are your
priorities different do you think about
different things
going from where you were before to now
i think there's two things tactically
when kovit started
we launched a couple of very nice covet
centric features like one good example
was
people were becoming remote so we
created this activity calendar where
teams could share their calendars and
look who they're selling to
very small feature but turns out that in
google you can look at somebody's
calendar
but first of all you have to stop
looking again and then it doesn't show
you which deals you're working on so you
only see meeting meeting meetings and
now we sort of
start and i see the whole team huge for
for like remote teams but
so that's tactically i think
strategically what's changed isn't due
to cover just like us being
you know maybe two years ago we were
maybe 100 people one year ago 200 people
now we're over 400 people
so just this footprint of us is a suite
of products so it's not no no longer
just conversation intelligence it's not
revenue intelligence it's not touching
just coaching
it's touching the core pipeline
management processes next year we're
going to do assistance selling
there's so much more we can do it kind
of broadens what my role is and the
product holders in general which is
accepting new value
position value areas where you can
pretty much become the new operating
system for we could be selling in a
couple of years
but you know at the end of the day it's
all about resources right it's all about
money
time relationships there is one chief
product officer you have 24 hours in the
day
and you now have you know 400 people
across the different divisions
each person you know reinventing
different things and different ideas and
different
you know pitches and at the end there's
one one elon
right and you know the company has to
focus
so how do you continue innovating or how
do you continue prioritizing
and keeping yourself in check that you
truly are prioritizing the right
24 hours in the day er every time i'm
assuming here working most of those
hours giving that
what i'm saying gone is happening no no
no i don't work i don't
believe in hard work like over over hard
work i think you want to run my
marathon's not sprint and you can't run
you know 100 miles per hour you know
forever so
i think there's two things first of all
you always want as a startup person
right you always want to hire smart
people right so i think
if you hire smart people yeah you know
you don't have to do that much because
other people do the smart things i think
the other thing for product specific
stuff the way we organize our teams are
it's called squads it's like every
pm ux and a group of engineers kind of
work together
almost their own startup so in the same
way they're like pretty independent
right so one is like
about coaching one is about pipeline
management one is about
assisted selling i mean so then you know
as us as leadership we don't have to
interfere so much i mean we
want to distract people from time to
time but generally they're pretty
self-sufficient
and i think personally is i don't
believe in this like i don't have enough
time kind of thing i mean if i don't
know if you've seen of some of the other
listeners here have kind of read through
this nice book called getting things
done
and i think the the gist of what they're
saying is you know you got a bunch of
things whatever you can do in a couple
of minutes just knock them out the rest
just crying where dies
if something that drops below the line
well i guess it's not important right so
there's no point in doing it i mean it's
just not happened but you you've kind of
consciously made a decision to make it
number 17
then you don't feel bad about it you can
go to sleep you don't have to work 24
hours a day
and if it's so important bring it to
number seven something else is going to
go down so i
yeah i don't believe in like you know
crazy work or like you know i'm stressed
i i don't feel stressed
sadly so i think that that is perhaps
the most inspiring thing that i'm taking
out of this the chief product officer of
a hybrid growth company
that is doubling year over year saying
yeah i don't believe in you know over
you know overworking or being stressed
that we're having fun and we're working
you know hard and and and what i'm
hearing from you is working
intelligently
right it's not about not working hard
but it's working intelligently and
with and very intentionally that's what
that's
yeah i don't know yeah i mean you
wouldn't you don't hear me saying not
working hard we work hard at least most
of us do
but first of all when we ask employees
you know can i you know
are you okay with kind of what we work
we generally get positive positive
feedback but
i think also um it's it's working hard
but reasonably hard because you don't
want to burn yourself right so
but you know it's i mean people call it
the start-up but it's a marathon it's
it's multi-years
you know i've had people in gong by the
way who i work with for
i'm going to stay a number here but he's
going to be stunned right for over 20
years
and so i mean the people who wouldn't
import with me if they all like burn
themselves so it's all about like
keeping those things
uh like in in in health and keeping
ourselves like a
you know kind of i love it inspired and
i want to do this more i love it elon
i'm already upset that we only have a
few minutes left but now i want to
i want us to talk to i want you to talk
to to me
and to the other young entrepreneurs and
engineers that are that are tuning in
either from you know stanford already
you know we're all you know extremely
excited to go on our own paths and
and hopefully create the next gong i
think that you know gong really
exemplifies you know
the you know the hunger that that so
many young entrepreneurs have especially
in 2021 especially
you know in the ecosystems we live in
and
this is a unique opportunity for me to
gauge kind of your insight
what types of things in your position
would you tell
young elon or young michael or
young santiago is listening what are
some things to keep in mind as we go
through our journey
um i would probably um
you know and probably one thing is is
when you think about a product
make just make sure you make one
customer really really happy
so don't focus like making everybody a
little bit happy just find this one
custom make them
really really happy and then kind of
worry about the second one make them
really really happy
and then the third one eventually if you
make people really really happy they're
gonna bring their friends and so on so
that's like
call it focus but it's really like
customer driven we call it raving fans
how do you make customers really
fantastic
it's more like make sure that you bring
a lot of value that's in the one thing
and i think on the
like personal and behavior kind of thing
this is my thing you don't have to be
there's like many
excuse my friends here right many jerks
have succeeded right but i think if you
can
be like a good person and like authentic
and work with other people i think that
helps too
probably not mandatory right but it's
it's kind of nice no definitely and i
think that being a mensch
is a i i've greatly enjoyed also working
with her dead
from j ventures and then you know
hearing mensch all the time it
kind of it rings about and i think that
it's it's definitely something amazing
talk to me a little bit more about this
raving fans idea why is it better
to have you know a small cohort of you
like super fans rather than
you know a much larger chord that says
yeah we enjoy what they're doing
they're a good group of they're a good
company um
first of all especially in the beginning
um there's the jeffrey moore thing you
know sort of like
you wanna you wanna companies bring
their people to bring their friends and
the way they're gonna bring their
friends if they're super excited if
they're kind of mindly excited they're
not gonna tell their friends
they're not gonna be great references so
first of all it's prerequisite for just
being successful and growing
and i think the other thing if you're
not super successful you're always
vulnerable so
right now we live in a crazy world in
terms of like company valuations and
startups and all what have you
there's always you know down downturns
and i think
if you are not bringing tons of value in
the first downturn they're gonna be the
first thing they're gonna turn off
um so it's always i mean my partner and
i both have been through the
2001 you know bubble bursting 2009
bubble bursting so i think there's also
the element of like
you want to protect yourself again those
situations where the market's going to
collapse you want to be one of those
systems the people are gonna be like i
can't live without him
like i'm not gonna let me tell you i'm
not gonna get rid of my dishwasher no
matter what
i'm probably gonna get rid of my
children before i get rid of my dishes
maybe not but you know what i'm saying
right so it's like you want to be one of
those things that are like a must-have
versus like
i don't know it's number 17 let's save
some budget i i love that elon i want to
thank you for being so generous with
your time i
enjoyed this episode so much talking
about focus talking about raving fans
talking about being a mensch
you know running marathons not sprints
and at the end of the day
i have to say like speaking with the
humbleness and the humility that you
bring to the table i think it's
inspiring and
it's inspiring me on the journey that i
want to go through and i'm sure that
other people that are listening it's
it's just as inspiring so so thank you
for all the amazing work that you're
doing both with gong
but but i'm guessing with every person
that you interact with so it was really
great
and the most important question is left
which is three words you would use to
describe yourself
wow and that's hard because you only
told me about it like 30 minutes exactly
that's the hardest question i have to
say
talking about not not having raving fans
i used to not even warn people
which was a horrible mistake because
then people were upset with me so now
i'm getting better slowly but i still
need to learn a little bit more in
advance
so i'm gonna i'm gonna have to just
reuse warts reviews already right so i
would say
authentic is one you know i'm a big
believer in being authentic being
yourself also important to other people
around me to be authentic um
probably be um self-motivated that's
tour so i got three now
i love it authentic and self-motivated
best of luck i can't wait to continue
being a super fan of what you're doing
i'm i'm one
one of the raving fans so thank you for
all the great work and stay safe and
stay healthy
thank you for hosting me today have a
great day